SMEARED AS A RACIST BY THE
LIBERAL MEDIA MOB.
WE REMEMBER THE CASE OF HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT NICHOLAS SANDMAN.
HE WAS SMEARED BY THE MEDIA AS
A HATEFUL RACISTS BECAUSE HE WAS
WEARING A MAGA HAT.
HE PUBLICED AN OP-ED OFFERING
HIS SUPPORT TO RITTENHOUSE
SLAMMING THE MEDIA FOR SPEWING
THEIR LIES.
HE ADDRESSES RITTENHOUSE
DIRECTLY WRITING.
JOINING NOW FOR AN EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW.
I REMEMBER AT THE TIME WHAT YOU
WERE GOING THROUGH.
I REMEMBER THAT MOMENT.
THE FACTS STARTED COMING OUT.
EVERYTHING THAT WAS SAID ABOUT
YOU, YOU HAD WALKED OVER TO THIS
IT NATIVE-AMERICAN ACTIVIST.
THAT YOU HAD -- YOU WERE A
RACIST.
YOU HAD THE SAME FALSE
ACCUSATIONS LEVELED AGAINST YOU.
I REMEMBER THINKING, WHEN THE
FACTS CAME OUT YOU HANDLED THIS
AS PERFECTLY AS ANY KID COULD.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS:
WHAT IS THE IMPACT ON THE PSYCHE
OF BEING THRUST INTO THE PUBLIC
EYE AND BEING CALLED THINGS THAT
YOU ARE NOT?
THINGS THAT ARE NOT TRUE?
WHAT DO YOU THINK KYLE SHOULD
DO?
>> WELL, IT'S TERRIBLE, SEAN.
I WILL TELL YOU WHY.
AS A 17-YEAR-OLD IN KYLE'S CASE
AND MINE 16.
YOUR MIND IS STILL DEVELOPING.
TO DEAL WITH AN OVERLOAD OF
STRESS WHERE YOU HAVE THIS
FEELING THAT HALF OF THE
COUNTRY, HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE HATE YOU FOR SOMETHING
THAT YOU ARE INNOCENT OF.
HOW YOU ARE PAINTED.
IT CAN DO A LOT TO YOU MENTALLY.
IT TAKES A VERY STRONG WILL TO
BE ABLE TO RESIST THAT AND KEEP
A LEVELHEAD.
I KNOW THAT KYLE RITTENHOUSE IS
DEALING WITH THAT RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: YOU SAID IN THIS
ARTICLE THE PARALLELS BETWEEN ME
AND KYLE RITTENHOUSE ARE
IMPOSSIBLE NOT TO DRAW.
YOU THINK THAT KYLE RITTENHOUSE
SHOULD SUE OUTLETS TO HOLD THE
MEDIA ACCOUNTABLE.
I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE ENTERED
INTO SETTLEMENTS AND I AM SURE
THERE ARE NONDISCLOSURE
AGREEMENTS.
I KNOW CNN IS ONE.
THERE ARE ON-GOING CASES, IS
THAT CORRECT?
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
I AM CURRENTLY STILL SUING SIX
MEDIA OUT LETS.
>> Sean: TELL US WHY YOU THINK
KYLE SHOULD HOLD THE MEDIA
ACCOUNTABLE?
I WOULD LIKE YOUR OPINION BASED
ON JOE BIDEN'S TWEET DO YOU
THINK HE SHOULD SUE JOE BIDEN?
>> WELL, I THINK HE SHOULD SUE
THE MEDIA.
BUT IT'S REALLY A PERSONAL CALL.
IN JANUARY IT WILL BE 3 YEARS
SINCE EVERYTHING HAPPENED AT THE
MARCH FOR LIFE.
I AM STILL LOOKING AT ANOTHER 2
YEARS UNTIL THE CASES THAT GO TO
IT TRIAL ARE RESOLVED.
IT'S A PERSONAL CALL.
I KNOW HE HAS A LOT ON HIS
PLATE.
ON THE TOPIC OF JOE BIDEN, I
HEARD A LOT OF DEBATE ABOUT IT.
I THINK PLAIN AND SIMPLE
UNFORTUNATELY CALLING SOMEONE A
RACIST OR A WHITE SUPREMACIST IS
AN OPINION PROTECTED BY THE
FIRST AMENDMENT.
MANY OF THE CLAIMS THAT WE
LABELED AS DEFAMATORY WERE NOT
LET IN BY THE JUDGE IN FEDERAL
COURT.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE HIM GO AFTER
JOE BIDEN.
BUT I DON'T THINK KYLE CAN BE
MAKING LAWSUITS JUST TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
HE DIDN'T HAVE THE LUXURY OF
SUING EVERYONE JUST TO SEE IF
ANY OF THEM LAND.
>> Sean: A LEARNED A LOT.
YOUR FIRST ATTORNEY WAS WOOD AND
HE WAS RICHARD JEWEL'S ATTORNEY.
I WAS A RADIO HOST IN ATLANTA AT
THE TIME.
A BIG ARTICLE CAME OUT IN THE
ATLANTA JOURNAL CONSTITUTION AND
SAID THAT RICHARD JEWEL FIT THE
PROFILE OF THE LONE BOMBER
BECAUSE HE LIVED WITH HIS
MOTHER.
RICHARD WAS LISTENING TO MY
RADIO PROGRAM.
I SAID JUST BECAUSE HE LIVES
WITH HIS MOM DIDN'T MAKE HIM
A DOMESTIC TERRORISTS.
HE WAS NOT RESPONSIBLE.
IN THE END HE WAS A HERO.
IT SERVED ME WELL.
I DON'T RUSH TO JUDGMENT.
THIS SHOW DOESN'T DO THAT.
WE ALLOW FOR THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE AND DUE PROCESS.
IN YOUR CASE, I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU WATCHED THE COVERAGE.
WE WERE RIGHT ON FERGUSON, AND
DUKE LACROSSE AND RIGHT ON THE
RUSSIA HOAX FOR 4 YEARS OF NEVER
ENDING CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND
LIES.
YOU HAVE THE SAME GROUP OF
PEOPLE THAT ALWAYS RUSH TO
JUDGMENT.
NEVER AFFORD DUE PROCESS OR THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE.
I BELIEVE YOU ARE RIGHT IN DOING
WHAT YOU ARE DOING.
THIS HAS TO END.
THEY ARE DESTROYING PEOPLE'S
LIVES.
YOU ARE A YOUNG MAN.
I CAN TELL FROM THIS INTERVIEW.
THIS HASN'T DESTROYED YOUR LIFE,
BUT IT COULD HAVE.
I AM SURE YOU HAD MANY DIFFICULT
DAYS IN THE PROCESS OF BEING
LABELED THE WORLD'S BIGGEST
RACIST.
>> YES.
IT WAS TERRIBLE FOR MULTIPLE
MONTHS.
I DON'T SPEAK ABOUT IT OFTEN.
IT'S BEEN HARD TO COME BACK FROM
THE STATE I WAS IN.
I DID WATCH A LOT OF FOX AND CNN
AND MSNBC.
I WATCHED EVERYTHING AFTER THE
CONFRONTATION HAPPENED.
IT WAS LIKE A CAR CRASH, YOU ARE
NOT ABLE TO LOOK AWAY.
MY EYES WERE GLUED TO THE TV.
WATCHING MY CHARACTER GET TORN
APART.
I KNOW KYLE WILL FACE THAT
JOURNEY OF GETTING BACK TO THE
PERSON THAT HE WAS BEFORE.
OF COURSE HE WON'T EVER BE THE
SAIL PERSON AGAIN.
-- SAME PERSON AGAIN.
IT'S A STRUGGLE.
>> Sean: THIS IS A BIG PROBLEM
WITH THE NEWS MEDIA.
YOU TOOK THEM ON.
IT LOOKS LIKE THAT YOU ARE
WINNING.
I WOULD IMAGINE YOU HAVE
A STRONG CASE IN EACH INSTANCE.
I WOULD PREDICT POSITIVE OUTCOME
FOR YOU.
YOU URGE KYLE TO CONSIDER THIS
PROCESS AS WELL.
HOW HAS IT CHANGED YOU BECAUSE
IT YOU SEEM STRONGER AS A RESULT
OF A IT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WOULD HAVE
CRUMBLED AND NEVER RECOVERED.
YOU SEEM TO HAVE RECOVERED.
>> YES.
THE BIGGEST THING THAT HAPPENED
TO ME AND WHAT I ALWAYS SAID I
BECAME AN ADULT AT 16.
I HAD TO LEARN VERY QUICKLY.
THE MOMENT I LEFT MY HOUSE,
THERE COULD BE A CAMERA ON ME.
I LEARNED TO LOOK AROUND AND
LOOK OVER MY SHOULDER IN PUBLIC.
NOT EVERYONE LIKES ME.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHERE I AM.
I STILL GET RECOGNIZED BY PEOPLE
ALL OVER EVEN TODAY.
IT MAKES YOU UNFORTUNATELY GROW
UP IN A LOT OF WAYS.
MOST 18 YEARS OLD DON'T WANT TO
DO.
THAT'S JUST THE UNFORTUNATE
REALITY OF WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA ATTACKS YOU IN
THE WAY THEY DID TO ME AND TO
KYLE.
>> Sean: I DON'T THINK YOU COULD
HAVE HANDLED IT MORE PERFECTLY.
I APPLAUD THE FACT THAT YOU WERE
ABLE TO WITHSTAND THAT, GROW AND
OBVIOUSLY MOVING ON WITH YOUR
LIFE.
I HOPE THAT KYLE RITTENHOUSE YOU
OFFERED HIM AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REACH OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE PROBABLY THE ONLY PERSON
IN THAT AGE GROUP THAT REALLY
UNDERSTANDS WHAT HE'S BEEN